what did you think was going to happen
when you started pe with joe
well firstly thanks for having me on the
call it's wonderful to be with two other
you know really
inspiring and caring people through such
a difficult time and
but that first day i think it's a year
to the day right that i did my first pee
with joe and
i had no idea how many people were going
to step in front we're going to so we're
going to be
at the end of that workout and it was
almost a million families worldwide and
you know i stuck with that i did it for
the almost a whole year and i'm so proud
that i was there for a difficult time
and i've got families
exercising together i got them feeling
good like it was really about mental
health and
it's my proudest achievement honestly
and i'm so glad and thank you all you
know to sky news for the very early days
when i was doing it you helped promote
it and
get more families involved so thanks for
your support as well
well thank you to you because in those
early days the kids were all sent home
from school they weren't necessarily
doing online school nobody really knew
how to begin how do you teach our kids
you gave us all some structure
some routines something for the whole
family to do
as you said what was the motivation
behind it
well i've always had a massive passion
for inspiring people to exercise and
i really shifted that focus towards
schools and
young people i was doing lots of uk
tours i was actually planning on going
on a
another tour around the uk visiting
schools and doing live workouts that
very monday that it was announced so
i just laid in bed one night and i said
to my brother i've got an idea why don't
i do a live workout and
you know take it digital and i put it
onto my youtube channel i had no idea
what's going to happen but you know
in the years since we had a 100 million
views worldwide from all over the world
and
it was really just something to give
parents a bit of you know a little bit
of breathing space give them some
structure today to start their sort of
academic learning and home schooling and
it was just a great idea it was just a
simple idea
um and i loved it i loved doing the
fancy dress and the quizzes and the spot
the difference i made it interactive so
that if
kid wasn't necessarily into the exercise
they'd still enjoy the quiz or the
spotlight difference and i
you know i loved it and i actually felt
really sad when it was over you know
because it was such an important part of
my life and such a
wonderful moment to be there for people
and um you had a bit of a calm down when
it all finished to be honest
yeah and no offense joe because it was
fantastic but i really
hope you don't have to do it again
because that will mean something
has gone wrong but what have you done
with all of those fancy dress
outfits from every friday
oh it's ridiculous my garage downstairs
i've got like a rail and just boxes and
boxes it must be about
45 fans of dress outfits and i was
buying a new one each week and i ran out
of ideas in the end i was you know i was
wearing
every disney character every kind of
marvel character but it was so fun doing
it and the kids loved it i dressed up as
the honey monster and banged my head i
tried to do the splits when i dressed up
as buzz lightyear
people remember all the silliness that's
what i think they love the music and the
dancing and that
you know me falling over and doing roly
polies with the kids and stuff and it
was
you know i love it and i really want the
legacy of people jokes to continue i
don't
want it to be something that you forget
about i want people to still be role
modeling to their kids be exercising as
a family it's such a powerful thing to
do when you've got
um young young children in the family to
inspire each other to exercise so it's
so important moving forward that
you do continue to stay active as a
family yeah and it was a family effort
for you as well wasn't it because you
roped in your wife
rosie and your two children indeed and
marley as well i think rosie really had
to step up after
you carried on through injury
yeah well i broke my hand i announced it
on the thursday
went out on the saturday crashed my
motorbike broke my hand and i carried on
on the monday i was there doing it but
halfway through the um the wires got
infected in my hand so i spent the night
in hospital
and i'm on the morning i said rosie i
need your help so she actually dressed
up in a
sports kit she was my teaching assistant
and you know bless her she was really
out of her comfort zone we had hundreds
of thousands of people tuned in
but yeah you know it's a team effort my
brother nikki was through every single
workout my brother nikki was in my
earpiece
doing the live shout outs i had rosie
helping me obviously with the kids and
trying to give me that half an hour to
do it and so it's a real
team effort you know i'm so proud of
everyone and you raised
a huge amount of money as well joe
didn't you
well recently yeah we actually raised
580 000 pounds for the nhs charities
together fund which was a combination of
youtube views and t-shirt sales from
this wonderful little pee with joe teach
that we made
and then more recently for lockdown
three i done um
he would joe i did um i raised money for
bbc children needs we raised 30 000
pounds it was obviously a much lower
views this time around but we're still
really tough that we managed to raise
some money from the youtube views to um
for children and needs they're really
focusing this year on
mental health for children really
helping them